white yellow tan brown red black blue
dead born living working discriminated
saddened these are the people I know and
these are the people MLK knew I started
the Martin Luther King Writing Awards in
1999 here on campus and they grew out of
my own interest and background in terms
of writing about race and when Carnegie
Mellon started formulating its ideas for
Martin Luther King Day in which there
and Student Affairs and I had this idea
of doing something with writing we
basically want to get as many voices as
we can involved so we expand the range
of voices in the hopes that we can
continue to have a diverse spectrum
participating in the awards there are
high school and college categories and
poetry and prose we invite the winners
to read on campus on Martin Luther King
Day they submit their work and we
publish a booklet of the winners every
year when I was born nickimja see this
is a pelvis gracefully we crossed my
future's love toward horizon rebuking
Cardinals for their blood prejudice I
heard there was often love loving and
as part of me ceaselessly with kindness
well I was particularly want to involve
young people whose ideas aren't too
solidly formed and are open to different
voices as we move forward from
generation to generation for the awards
and in the spirit of dr. King we think
it's more important to examine our own
lives so we ask for is personal
narratives on race I I think the
students are very brave in terms of
tackling these subjects and we want to
create a safe space where they can talk
honestly the combination of high school
in college ends up bringing in people
from a lot of different experience who
often have something in common and that
people have treated them differently
treated discriminated against them based
on externals we had a young student from
Allderdice high school was an immigrant
from Ghana who wrote a very emotional
piece this past year about being an
immigrant to this country I think that's
why it's important to have the awards
read aloud and to bring the winners
together to be in that room where
they're owning their words there's a lot
of heart in these awards and I think
that's one of the things that makes them
special they're not writing academic
pieces they're saying my life is
important and what happened to me is
important and maybe there's a little
something we can all learn from
you